In this video, I will show you how I
personally refine and identify the areas
for the best entry using orderflow.
Specifically, we will see one indicator
that show you the exact area called
delta print. This is not based on some
support and resistance or technical
indicators is based on actual orderflow
data that got executed previously. So
don't expect that this area can be seen
only from candlesticks. Hello everyone
and welcome back to the channel. In this
video I'm showing you two execution that
I took. One in London session and one in
New York session using this orderflow
suite of deep charts based on fixed
profile volume analysis and deep trades
analysis of the momentum of the market.
So we need to start with the profile
shape. The first thing that I was
checking here is that the London session
start with clear
breakout of the previous level a lot of
aggression here and they created a
condition of trend scenario. Why?
Because they accepted after the breakout
below the value area low. So as you can
see in this condition we are seeking new
balance of price and what we can expect
here is direction. So I didn't took the
first movement because it was before the
opening of the London session but the
second movement was so clear. What
happened here? You can see that here
there is this area. Okay. And this area
is based on the profile as you can see
of the previous swing point. This is
dynamic. Okay. So you can measure how
much pressure there was in the market
during this wing point using the delta
profile and using the big trades as you
can see the most important price level
and we don't need discretional analysis
here because you can see is when the
volume got support by these big trades
and this is the reason you see there is
a lot of delta pressure on this area.
Okay. So what we can expect is that if
we want to continue to go short, we will
reload other aggressive short position
from this area. So you can just put an
alert here. It's nice to notice also
that the value area high it's here. So
you have a confluence of value area
high, big trades and delta level. This
one is a super strong area. What
happens? The market tried to approach
this level, but as soon as the market
approaches this level, you see
aggressive sellers really strong here
and I will show you how much it's useful
to see dynamic data entering. Please
take care about this part of the chart
and watch as the price develop. Okay,
bum. You see all this volume? This is
what they did in these big trades. And
now we want to check if buyers can break
this level or they will continue to be
on this one because the pressure of the
seller is super strong. So we trace this
level. We have our area and this one
it's already an execution that you can
make protecting yourself above the area
that we already identified. Okay. Now
what the market does is that it tried to
break these big trades. Okay. But it
collapsed down again. So as you can see
we can expect that in the fractal
analysis we have another strong area
that will be protected by this
aggressive sellers and this is exactly
what's happening. So you can take also a
re-entry here covering above the area
targeting for a swing point. This is a 1
2 3 1 2 4 1 2 5. It depends on how much
you want to be safe on the stop-loss
placement.
By the way, this is our deep charts
platform [music] that is finally
available at a super discounted price
only for the next few days. So if you
are interested in learning orderflow and
having an actual platform that show you
real data if you want to join with my
link in the description, [music] you
will also get included one month
educational boot camp. Other than this,
we see that the market create again a
new dealing range. So after you go to
take profit on the first one, you have a
condition again of super strong swing
point, super aggression of the market.
Okay, really directional. And if you put
here the fixed profile, you see that the
most relevant area that you have here is
this clear volume ledge. Volume ledge is
where the the volume goes from really
peak point to really low point. Okay? So
from high volume node to low volume node
really fast. And if you want to be
precise, this area is this one. Okay.
But you cannot just execute based on
this. So you need to go to check what's
happening here in details. And if we go
in details to see what is happening
here, we can clearly see that this
battle of the sellers got won by
sellers. Why?
Aggressive orders deep trades in the
body of the candle. So actually
following results and absorption of the
aggressive buyers. What does it mean
that in this battle to create this down
movement buyers try to take control
again but they got absorbed. So all this
from the aggressive sellers to the
absorption of the buyers become our area
and the market like to retrace and go
here. So you can see that here control
of the buyers, control of the of the
buyers, control of the buyers, control
of the buyers, failed buyers. Okay. So
this kind of information is not based on
delayed data. You have this information
in real time and you can use them as a
confirmation to execute your trades.
Okay, this one could have been another
amazing execution with really high
probability following the direction of
the market. Okay. Now, if we go to
analyze what's happening here, we have
absorbed buyers, aggressive sellers that
put a lock on the movement and again
absorbed buyers. Okay. So, after this
candle, the situation is super clear.
So, you can already put a limit order
here. Okay. From here, the market
collapse. This is a really clear
understanding of auction market theory.
Sensitive high probability reversal area
following the direction of the trend and
trigger execution using deep trades that
is based not on some fancy algorithm or
secret source that move the market but
actual execution no conspiracy theory
just visualization of order entering the
market. Remember that the only thing
that move price is volume. You need an
execution, okay, for the market to
auction high or down. I hope you enjoy
this kind of content and I will see you
in the next